- And just because somebody
else can't see your vision
doesn't mean that it's not
a powerful vision for you.
But if you don't love what you're doing,
run for your life.
We need to stop whining
about what isn't happening,
what we don't have, what we can't do,
what somebody didn't do.
The truth will cut through all the drama,
all the misunderstanding, all the hurt,
all the pain, all the memories.
I got something for you:
refuse to fail!
Like, being wrong is almost
a fatal disease or something,
like it'll drop and die on the spot
if we have to say "I was wrong".
Be authentic.
My car got a name.
I say "Gracie, how you're
doing this morning?
"Come on, we going traveling".
Also, be really clear
about what it is you want.
Talk to yourself about it.
Clarity is a gift,
and it grows and develops
through practice.
- She's an American inspirational speaker,
author, life coach, lawyer
and television personality.
- She's known for her books
and appearances on the Oprah Winfrey Show.
- She's considered one of the 100
most spiritually influential
living people in the world.
- She's Iyanla Vanzant,
and here are her top 10 rules for success.
- Three things I want you to
do to nurture your vision.
I want you to affirm it every day.
Affirm it every day.
And don't affirm as, "I'm
trying", "I wish", "I want to".
"I am"!
Let me hear you say "I am".
- I am!
- Every single day,
"I am" is the creative
force of the universe!
Whatever you attach "I
am" to you will become.
You know, people say "I'm broke".
(audience laughing)
Or "I'm single".
No.
"I'm waiting for my ideal
mate to present himself to me
"in a way that I recognize".
(audience cheering and laughing)
Whatever you attach "I am" to.
"I'm confused". No.
"I'm awaiting clarity in this moment".
So affirm your vision every day.
And just because somebody
else can't see your vision
doesn't mean that it's not
a powerful vision for you.
Here's another key for you:
never judge your clarity on
how other people respond.
Did you hear me?
They will say, "What you doing? You crazy?
"Why you're doing that? You can't do that!
"Who told you you can do that?
"Who do you think you are?"
I love that one. "Who
do you think you are?"
"Me".
Affirm your vision. Clarify your vision.
Know what you're doing,
why you're doing it
and how you're doing it.
Day by day, moment by moment.
And sometime the how only shows
up on a need-to-know basis.
Don't wait for the how until
you stop pursuing your vision,
you understand?
Don't wait for the how.
Sometimes you just have to walk blindly,
but if you just do your vision,
every single day, putting one
foot in front of the other,
committed to your desires, being obedient,
walking through your fears,
the vision will unfold much grander
than you could have ever
even imagined or asked for.
So, this is what I say.
To support your vision,
instead of begging for it,
pleading for it, pray "Oh, God, please.
"Please, God. Please.
"Oh, God, please. Please, God, please.
"Oh, Allelu, allelu ..."
Be still.
Let your daily spiritual practice
be one of stillness and listening.
Listen for the instruction
instead of begging for the direction.
Listen. Be still.
I don't care what it is that
you're doing in this world.
I know many of you're involved
in the government here,
and we have so many elected officials
and people who are serving
the world in so many ways,
but if you don't love what
you're doing, run for your life.
Run for your life.
(audience applauding)
If find that in three days out of the five
you do in your work you
complain more than you bless,
run for your life.
If you're continually looking
at what your don't have,
what people aren't doing,
as opposed to looking
how blessed you are in that position,
run for your life.
You got cooties and you
need to run for your life.
So, I have this thing
that I've been promoting
called "No whining Wednesdays".
Wednesday you cannot whine,
complain or criticize.
And people are like,
"Well, what is whining?"
Whatever you think it is, don't do it.
And every time you do it you
have to put a quarter in a jar.
If you whine about anything,
"I can't", "I'm kind of ...",
"Why to me?", "Why don't you ...?",
"Why haven't ...?"
Every one of that will cost you a quarter.
Or complaining, "Why don't you ...?",
"Why do you always ...?",
"How come you ...?",
"I have always ...", "They never ..."
Cost you a quarter.
Then last week I had
people sent me pictures
of their jars of quarters.
Oh, my God. (laughs)
But what they said to me
also was "this was wonderful
"because I was never, ever aware
"of how much whining and
complaining and criticizing I do".
Now I've got mothers doing
it with their children.
So Wednesday is "No whining Wednesday".
We need to practice that.
We need to stop whining
about what isn't happening,
what we don't have, what we can't do,
what somebody didn't do.
We got to get it cleaned in 2014.
No whining, no complaining,
no criticizing.
Keep it simple.
The truth will cut through all the drama,
all the misunderstanding, all the hurt,
all the pain, all the memories.
Keep it simple.
I don't care how long you've
been with Fifi or Bubu,
if they leave you is not because
something's wrong with you,
they ain't the one for you!
Keep it simple.
You got laid off from your job?
There's another divine
opportunity waiting for you to --
Keep it simple.
You lost your house? Well,
in your father's house
there are many men, gents.
Just hang around long enough.
Keep it simple.
The path to greatness:
order,
vision,
trust,
faith,
a good piece of chocolate,
(audience laughing)
and simplicity.
I've got something for you:
refuse to fail!
(audience applauding)
Refuse!
Just refuse to fail!
And if what you're doing looks like
it's going to move you toward
failure, do something else.
Look at me. Refuse to fail.
I refuse to fail.
Now, that may mean that
I have to walk barefoot,
it may mean that I have
to sleep in a park,
it may mean that I have to ask for help,
it may mean that I have
to give something up,
it may mean that I have to stop --
But I refuse to fail.
We like to be right. Yeah.
Like being wrong is almost a
fatal disease or something,
like it'll drop and die on the spot
if we have to say "I was wrong", you know?
So, if we look around
and anybody challenges us
we'll give up what we believe.
So, here is one of the
things that I learned
on my journey to peace.
I don't need your agreement.
I'm asking for your support.
(audience applauding)
I don't need your agreement.
Not going to get people to
agree with what you know in here
'cause they don't know
that thing in there.
Never judge your clarity based
on somebody else's response.
When you're clear, you're clear.
Hold to your clarity.
And if people look like they
judge you, close your eyes.
Be authentic.
Many people don't even
know what that means.
It means that you're
clear about who you are,
you're clear about your purpose,
your protocols and your plans,
you're clear about what you're up to,
and you speak the truth
of that all the time.
Be authentic.
It means you're in integrity.
That what you think, what you say,
what you feel and what you do all matter.
Now, I know that's hard in Washington
'cause there's just some
truths you can't tell out here,
but we want to do the best that we can.
And when you can't, pray about it.
But be authentic.
So many of us don't allow
people to know who we are.
As I travel around this
country I meet people
all over the country who
are suffering in silence
because they're not authentic
about what they need,
what they want, what they're doing,
what they're experiencing.
Let's clean up our mouths,
how we say what we say,
and who we say it to.
Do you know you can talk
yourself into trouble?
A lot easier that you can
talk yourself out of it.
But if you become mindful
about what you're speaking
it'll be a lot easier to
handle some of the things
that come up in your life with speaking.
Years and years and years
ago I learned a secret.
I used to open my pocketable, my purse,
I'd get right down over it and I'd say,
"Fill yourself with divine
substance right now!"
(audience laughing)
"Oh, you, look at all that abundance
"just pouring down right at --
"Oh!" (laughs)
I named everything and
I speak to everything.
My car got a name.
I say, "Gracie, how
you're doing this morning?
"Come on, we're going traveling".
My house got a name,
Villanova, the big vision.
I'm mindful of my mouth,
because I know that what
comes out of my mouth
must be creative.
Everything begins with a word.
So, we even want to stop speaking about
how horrible our children are doing,
or how bad people are doing,
or how bad things are.
Well, here's an affirmation,
"Oh, my, I can't hardly wait
"to see the good that's
going to come out of this",
no matter what it is,
as opposed to you using our
power to continue to affirm
what's wrong, what's
broke, what ain't working,
what's not happening, how horrible it is.
Let's speak life into things.
Let's speak life into our children.
Let's speak life into our
families, into our relationships.
I can't tell you the number of
people who write me and say,
"I need you to help me
with my crazy family".
Well, they're your family.
(audience laughing)
(laughs)
I don't even know that kind
of crazy you got over there.
This is just what I'd be thinking
and then I'd bless my head
so that that thought will go away.
But, what if we started saying,
"Well, I know it looks
like Bubu, my cousin,
"is having difficulty right now,
"but I see a brighter day for you"?
It's what Emmet Fox called "Golden key",
when you key something up
with the radiant richness
of what you wanted to be as opposed
to affirming it as it is
right now, as it is right now.
So we want to clean up our mouths
of what we say about each other.
Imagine that you have 24 hours a day
for how many years.
How much of that time do
you give just for you,
where you just sit and
be present with you,
self care and self nurturing?
Also, being really clear
about what it is you want.
Talk to yourself about it.
Talk to somebody you care about about it.
Hear your own voice and
honor your own feeling,
and be good to you.
Be clear
about who you are and what you're up to
at any given point in time.
Be clear about what matters
to you, what you value,
what you will do, what you
won't do, what you can do
and what you can't do.
Be clear. Clarity is a gift,
and it grows and develops
through practice.
Be clear. Be clear about who you are.
Many, many years ago, when I
first started doing this work
and I was writing, I
wrote a little purple book
called "Acts of Faith",
and the book had a life all of its own.
And I was running all over speaking
and talking about "Acts
of Faith" and stuff,
and making money on the book,
speaking for $50 and $300 and $200.
I had to get clear, 'cause
I had $500 worth of clothes.
It was not profitable.
But I had to get clear.
And Dennis Kimbro said this to me
right in the halls of the
old convention center.
He said, "Iyanla, be
clear about what you are.
"Are you a writer who speaks
or a speaker who writes?"
Sometimes, when we do multiple things,
we throw them all together
and we practice each and we master none.
Be clear about who you are,
about what you do, what you're up to,
what is your primary cause
of action and call to action.
You got to be clear.
And listening to what
Dennis Kimbro said to me,
was I a speaker who writes
or a writer who speaks,
I said, "Well, I ain't none of that.
"That's something that I do,
but that's not who I be".
Who you be?
You've got to get clear about who you be,
because being is an internal state,
it's not about doing,
it's what drives you,
what elevates you, what you will do
every single day of your life
for the rest of your life
whether you got paid or not.
That's who you be.
What matters to you, that's who you be.
What you value, that's who you be.
And so many of us are clear
about what we have to do
but not clear about who
we be as we're doing it,
'cause some of us want to serve people,
and we end on a wet cap
on any given Sunday.
Get clear about who you be.
- Thank you so much for watching.
- We made this video
because Jessica Salter
asked us to.
If there's anyone that you
would like us to feature
please leave a comment below.
- I'd also love to know
which of the 10 rules
hit you the hardest,
had the greatest impact
on your life and why.
Leave in the comments and
we'll join the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching,
and continue to believe.
And we'll see you soon.
- Bye.